c'est ta première fois bonjour et
bienvenue caroline d'arrêter de bosser à
trois mois avant il sincèrement qu'elle
avait traîné dans la poterie les quais
dans soho franchement c'était réel comme
contrôle trade caroline st bon j'espère
un petit resto noël tonkin et un j'en ai
j'ai que ça à même
enlevez moi d'un doute aucun autre
témoin j'ai trop bu on fait du pas
pourquoi
égrenant du gringue
parfois dans leurs tirs c'était un
hasard
on arrose tétouan deuxième poste encore
toi troisième c'était moi pour le dîner
ce soir de près du coin il vas t'ennuyer
a maintenant bien sûr la dînée ne sait
pas depuis quand même ce kindle fait
marcher là il y en aura marre de coucher
avec sa mère
qu'est ce que tu fais discuter de quoi
totalisant torride avec un type ya là
j'ai donc fait je crois que ça aurait
marché entre même si on se rencontre et
à des moments différents de nos vies je
n'étais pas prête
j'ai la chance à un jeu trouvait au bon
moment
c'est ridicule ouais
je suis pas un bon contenu déjà
m
diamant
ag